rive Badawi has paid a high price for
expressing his opinion he has already
suffered 50 of the 1,000 lashes has been
sentenced to his blog calling for a
secular liberal Saudi Arabia no longer
exists online but the texts have now
been published in book form in Germany
Amnesty International is calling for his
release they say he's a prisoner of
conscience whose only crime was to set
up a website inviting public discussion
you texted saying in the text show that
this is a legitimate form of expression
which also has to be respected in a
state like Saudi Arabia it's not
something that someone should be locked
up for or sentenced to a dreadful
punishment such as flogging columns da
vida mas perch and water be under that
contravenes all the human rights
standards that we advocate in badami was
arrested back in 2012 hundreds of
spectators watched the first flogging in
January outside a mosque in Jeddah
subsequent rounds of punishment were
postponed for medical reasons the
anthology of his writings in German has
been compiled by the journalist
Konstantin Shriver an English edition is
expected soon